so hey guys hi hi hello hi so first of
all congratulations on putting one piece
together we saw the the first trailer
yesterday we're very excited I'm a fan
so I can tell you amazing
uh so so the first thing I want to ask
you guys is uh are you a fan of anime do
you like I know Emily likes anime yeah
right yes yes what anime do you like
give me that Mike
let him sir what are you asking I'm
Japanese
am I a fan of anime I grew up with anime
I have a specific question for you yeah
yes yes okay cool and then I have to go
forward too yeah I'm sorry I skipped a
lot of people huh no it's fine I had two
two write it down
you did uh Knights of the zodiac yeah
right you did Ronnie Kenshin yes you did
Full Metal Alchemist yes you did Brave
yes and Tokyo yes
you've done it all so thank you thank
you is there is there any anime
adaptation that you would like to do in
the future you know what it's not
something I would like to do but my
favorite one of my favorite anime is
Hunter Hunter which I love so uh shout
out to Andre Okay yeah who would you
play
no I will not play anyone oh come on
okay all right so the rest of you which
anime do you like
I'm a fan of Trigon yo yes it's a good
show we used to get a lot of anime on TV
in Spain so what about you I mean before
watching One Piece I didn't really uh
watch a lot of anime
um before doing one piece sorry um after
filming one piece I did uh get into
anymore I'm honestly like like one piece
is like my thing I tried chainsaw man I
think it's really cool but it's a little
too violent
player right now I was watching that in
the airplane and I I really really loved
the first episode I thought it was so
good so I think I'm gonna stick with
Demon Slayer and the one piece for a
while I think it's gonna take me some
time attacking Titan first grade or Jiu
Jitsu Kaizen if you like Demon Slayer
you would also like there's a show
called Jiu Jitsu Kaizer
so close man so this is this your
favorite um uh my favorite anime is
called Maiden Abyss but
um I you know I love Demon Slayer and
jjk Tokyo Ghoul like I've I've watched
too many to name them all I feel like
those are mandatory right if you oh
absolutely yeah I'm naming I'm naming
like the ones that are the basics like
if you want to learn you get into them
but yeah Maiden Abyss I would say is my
top okay okay uh so this is for you all
I want to know what are you most excited
for people to see one piece finally
premieres do you want to start uh what
are we most excited for them to see oh
uh God I mean the Sea Beast is one of my
favorite things that that they killed it
with the special effects on the Sea
Beast
um
man what the action really good action
sequences thank you
[Laughter]
I'm so excited for everyone to see like
the amazing characters of one piece I
think everybody on the cast did an
amazing job with their characters and I
am just so excited to you know bring the
straw hats to more people and to the
people who are already fans to be able
to relive those amazing iconic moments
again so yeah okay I see that you have a
very uh positive and
big energy right like Luffy right uh so
is is he like they're different from you
or are you like that you have that
energy all the time oh he's like that
he's definitely like that I mean I you
were you were Luffy from the start
I um I do have a lot of Luffy inside me
I've always been a very energetic uh
person that's for sure I love to
celebrate I love to eat I I do feel like
him in a lot of ways I also feel like I
can learn a lot from him
um unlike Luffy sometimes I do second
guess myself and I do have insecurities
I think when I play Luffy I I feel
inspired to be stronger and be more
Brave so there's a lot that I share with
Luffy there's also a lot that I can
learn from him too that's great that's
great uh so I want to ask you guys now
do any of you get a chance to talk to
before filming
um I had an opportunity to meet Mr Oda I
cannot get too into detail about it but
I did have an opportunity to um interact
with him I also was able to meet Oda
Sensei and it was
um easily the most scared I've ever been
in my whole life not because he's a
lovely dude but you know he's like he's
kind of like a god you know oh my God so
I was like oh man I can't hello it's so
nice to meet you like just shaking I
wouldn't say kind of you no okay all
right all right I was softening that but
you're right you're right
uh so we're obviously not gonna do like
1 000 episodes right because live action
is a lot more expensive but I want to
know oh that's you can answer this how
long would you like for this series to
go I'd like it to go for exactly as long
as it takes to
feel like it's come to an ending that
all of us are happy and and by us I mean
the greater us of us five and every
single person involved I want everybody
to be proud of where we end up ending
otherwise and short and I don't want it
to run long that's my ideal yeah that's
a great answer yes I don't have anything
to say
that was the best dance yeah I think you
nailed it yes yes so of course I don't
need to say it but we all know um one
piece is a huge huge huge title and I
want to know from you during filming did
you feel did you ever feel the pressure
of having to put together something as
big as this uh
pressure makes diamonds baby
[Applause]
wow that's a guy right there there's a
guy right there
[Laughter]
right there uh what about you Mike and
you've been you've been in many
adaptations right so how does this one
differ from the other ones or is it the
same
um they're all different in their own
special ways but this one was
definitely the biggest
long going manga ever so uh there was
pressure but I've kept my focus on the
roles and how to bring Zara to life
and he kills it he's great
he is
all right so whereas from you last next
is uh was there a moment during filming
you filmed in Cape Town right yes yeah
Cape Town uh so was there uh a set piece
or a location that you really liked you
you thought it was this is awesome I
want people to see that I mean
all the sets are amazing I I mean I I
gotta go with like going marry you know
I I think every set is amazing but to go
in there specifically it just has so
much emotion in it right so if there is
like one piece of set I really want
people to see It's gotta be the go and
marry one piece
oh also um actually there is one other
said that I really loved uh Luffy's
first boat yes his first his first boat
ever yes that is also special
yeah and then it's also emotional right
because it's a the beginning uh what
about you the the rest of you Emily I
yeah I mean obviously the Mary is
extremely special that was something
that I think for all of us seeing it in
person for the first time stepping foot
on it was
um a dream you know and uh I guess
there's um there's a set in Kaya's
Mansion where our designer took what
used to be an indoor pool and actually
made it into a sunken kitchen and I was
just like you know people I want to be
creative like that like I would never
look at an empty pool and be like let's
make that a kitchen it was and it looked
beautiful it was so cool I'm like I'm on
my house my real house to have that okay
right so I have time for one more
question uh so I'd like to know if you
guys have any message that you'd like to
send for One Piece fans that are like me
who are eager to see the series
man we I think we're just as excited to
share it with you all there's there's
been so much love and like Taz was in
there's so many people involved on the
project and
we're just so proud of everyone's work
so
it's exciting to share
what about you
well
I love the manga I love the anime and I
know you will love the live action too I
am super excited about this project we
put our heart and soul into it and uh
you know I hope that you are entertained
but beyond that I hope that if you see
our show you decide to also go chase
your dreams that's great okay so thank
you guys I love your energy I'm excited
for the show and thank you so much thank
you so much